this is the 3m and 95 mask it's
ubiquitous by now there's another type
of mask called an n95 or respirator mask
what I want to show you guys is these
n95 respirators and 95 masks that 3m is
so crucial to production of an hour
intern so crucial to our healthcare
workers it usually costs around one
dollar it's one of the most essential
pieces of equipment to keep healthcare
workers safe while fighting the
coronavirus by filtering out 95% of all
airborne particles hence the name and 95
it's also an extremely short supply well
as a corona virus continues to spread
the demand for n95 respiratory masks
around the world is also growing the
masks should be for the health care
workers the public should not be buying
masks but there are other masks besides
the n95 this is the FFP two masks from
Europe it keeps out 94% of airborne
particles this is the K n95 mask from
Asia it keeps out 95% of airborne
particles yet the u.s. cannot import any
of these during the crisis we're really
trying to dig into the exactly why this
is happening on it on a daily basis but
it looks for now like the government
simply did not have enough of these
things on hand to respond immediately
the federal government reportedly had 12
million masks in its stockpile the US
will reportedly need 3.5 billion masks
during this pandemic there's a myriad of
reasons why we have insufficient
stockpiles the role of government is the
plan for crises to stockpile masks so
that if we ever have a pandemic we have
enough masks on hand and it looks like
the government didn't do its part of the
job there and we do have a federal
agency and a CDC that has been
systematically underfunded
we haven't received the right pieces
that haven't invested in the stockpiles
over the years because of the short
supply black markets have popped up
overnight where prices for the n95 have
more than quintupled an investigation
into ha
of thousands of medical-grade mass that
were just sold at auction 43 year-old
Baruch feldheim
is accused of selling a thousand n95
masks to a doctor at a 700 percent
markup if you go to Craigslist you can
find n95 mask going for hundreds of
dollars states are also all in a bidding
war with one another to procure these
masks and inflated prices if you have
the capacity to make these products we
will purchase them and we will pay a
premium but the federal government says
that they are not at fault for the
shortage the notion of the federal
stockpile was it supposed to be our
stockpile it's not supposed to be state
stockpiles that they then use so we're
encouraging the states to make sure that
they're assessing the needs they're
getting the data from their local local
situations and then trying to fill it
with the supplies that we've given them
so with the government stockpile not
being the answer other avenues needed to
be explored to fulfill the spike in
demand just one problem we have our own
Food and Drug Administration we have our
own regulatory bodies we have our own
standards and we tend to gravitate
towards importing things that we know
and that we're comfortable with and
that's where the n95 mask comes in but
also remember you know this isn't just
stockpiles from a federal stock point
point of view but also the broader
supply chain 3m produces a large amount
of respirator masks but they aren't the
only ones there are about 50% of face
masks are produced in China for example
and there are big suppliers that exist
globally and remember those alternative
masks we were talking about in the
beginning country equivalent standards
do not fly in America because they're
not approved by the FDA or the National
Institute for Occupational Safety and
Health
despite being equivalent masks but these
standards are also and this is something
we're seeing here again in this crisis
can be a barrier to trade and it can be
a barrier to getting supplies in into
the right into right places the the
masks that are currently produced in
China are right now not approved for
export or import into the United States
is a class 1 medical device which puts a
restriction on the amount of supply so
without a sufficient stockpile and
options limited overseas America has to
look inward the federal government is
calling on the private sector to help
fill the need of medical supplies
Honeywell
will be the latest company to pivot and
prioritize public health by producing
n95 masks at its facility here in
Phoenix New Balance says many of its US
factories including one in Lawrence are
now producing face masks for hospitals
we're seeing automakers start to get
into the business of making ventilators
we're seeing the distillers starting to
make hand sanitizer there's a huge
ramping up of industrial America that is
happening much as we saw during the
Second World War and in previous Wars
but with the first shipment of masks
from China landing in New York in early
April and Trump enacting the defense
production act to manufacture more masks
and respirators domestically millions of
masks are being made available but it's
not enough the solutions that we need
and one of the key lessons that I hope
we also get out of this in order to be
able to diversify our supply chains to
make sure that we've got sufficient
inventory it requires us to take a
global view and and a global piece so
that we can move product and move
support from one region that is being
impacted today to another that's going
forward we're again at one of those
moments where when you respond to a
global crisis like Cove at 19 the answer
is taking care of things at home but
also of learning from your neighbors
you
you